There's another misconception that
happens that leads people to believe
being the seventh best player is okay,
which is well, if the winner is
generating 500 million in revenue and
we're generating 50 million in revenue,
we're just worth like onetenth of the
winner. I don't think I've ever seen
this thought backed up. In fact, I think
that the assumption is you're going to
trend towards having no revenue. Yes.
This is Dalton plus Michael. Today, what
we're going to talk about are some
nonobvious insights we've had on how you
actually make a very large company. I
think what I'd like to explore is how
maybe the advice that we give
pre-product market fit is slightly
different than the advice that we give
postp product market fit. I think
sometimes founders uh don't get this
right. So
>> yeah. So I mean I think to start with uh
disclaimer.
>> Yeah,
>> this is a nuance topic.
>> This is the this is a fantastic example
of something that I'm happy to speak
about on video and would never in a
million years put on X or social media
which nuance doesn't work. Even even
writing blog posts, it had to be a very
long blog post. This is super nuanced.
And so the nuance here is pre PMF
you just need an idea and you just need
to make something that people want. And
so much of the advice is to stay out of
midwand.
>> Yes.
>> So much of the advice is
>> to quiet your mind. Yes.
>> From all the distractions, all the, you
know, super fancy strategizing you think
you're doing and just like go do the
thing.
>> Yes.
>> And that's how I would summarize lots
and lots of the prepf advice is just go
do the thing. Less strategy, more help
the customer,
>> more just do things.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And those people win. Again, here
comes the nuance. Uh
>> oh.
>> What we will totally acknowledge is that
post PMF, if all you do is that same
premiumf strategy, you can end up in a
local maxima.
>> Yes. More common
than I ever thought. And I think that
there is this
false belief that if I can make $10
million, I can make $100 million, I can
make $500 million. Actually, it us often
starts at $1 million.
>> Yep.
>> The thing that makes me $1 million can
make me a billion dollar. What's
unfortunate
is how easy it is to verify that's not
true. Like what's unfortunate is you can
look at a lot of software companies and
ask what did they do to make their first
million and is that how they're making
all their money now and for just as many
examples as you would find in the
positive you'd find in the negative like
Google monetizing search monetizing
search Microsoft yeah completely
different completely different get into
the nuance here
>> yeah I think the way I I would set up
this is to say let's use the Facebook
example I like to use them just cuz it's
now everyone knows it's a big company,
but we remember when it was not a big
company.
>> Yes.
>> And at the time when it was a small
startup,
>> it had the best social network for
college students.
>> Yes.
>> And it basically had a monopoly for
people that had aedu email address.
>> Yes.
>> And at the time, you had to be a student
at one of the universities that they
supported. Otherwise, you couldn't use
it. Nope.
>> That was part of what made it cool is
there were no parents on it. There were
no kids on it.
>> It was a feature. It was a feature that
was super easy. It also restricted you
to only your university.
>> Yes.
>> And so they built a super sticky
product, but at the time the
conventional wisdom is
>> this is some college kid niche social
network.
>> How can that be?
>> How can that be a big business? This is
by its very definition niche.
>> Yes. And then if we look back in time,
the strategic decision that was not hill
climbing, it was not, you know, heading
to local maxima was to first allow high
school students to come in.
>> No, first it was the it was first the
companies that a lot of the Ivy League
kids went to work at.
>> That was before high school kids.
>> That was before high school kids. Yeah.
It was uh it was like Accenture. Oh,
sure.
>> Yeah. It was some of the I remember
those some of the first some of the
first nonedus that came up. Yeah. So
Accenture was in that's
>> I think Accenture got in before some
high colleges got in.
>> That's a departure from the original
vision. Then high school kids was a
really big departure.
>> And then the decision to allow all
people to sign up. Yes.
>> I would argue is a great example of a
big strategic bet.
>> Yes.
>> That was not related to just hill
climbing what they were doing.
>> No.
>> Then there was the big strategic bet to
do mobile.
>> Yes.
>> Which was betting the betting the farm
on the mobile app was a big strategic
bet. All the money they were making was
on web at the time,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> Then there was the Facebook app store
strategic bet. There was the Facebook
phone strategic bet which didn't work
out. Like there Instagram
>> which is basically the company now.
>> Yes. It's save the company. With
hindsight, you can see all these times
where the founder had to make a decision
that was not hill climbing making the
product better. Yes.
>> It was actually
>> making kind of a crazy bet and betting
the company on something. Yes. And with
hindsight, those ones worked out. But
remember back in 2005, 2006, there were
a bunch of VC funded social networks. I5
>> Yep.
>> tagged.
>> And for whatever reason, those companies
>> didn't make these types of moves or to
the extent they made strategic moves,
those moves did not work out. A takeaway
from this story is if you're going to
build a very very large and successful
social network, probably the best way to
monetize it is through advertising.
You have to figure out how to be huge.
And there are a lot of other network
effects that come in being huge. But if
we just think about the business
perspective, right, the value to an
advertiser for everyone being in one
place and the amount of premium you can
charge,
massive. You don't get that value if
you're the seventh place player. I'm
sure there are a lot of other product
reasons why this whole path made a lot
of sense, but the business reason
effectively able to make Facebook to
make them revenue, it does. And I think
that sometimes when we're talking to
startups,
I get the impression they care far more
about what they believe their next
fundraising milestone is
than what number they'd have to hit to
IPO. What number would they have to hit
to be a $50 billion valuation company in
the public market? What company they'd
have to hit to be a hundred billion
dollar? And sometimes
you are inadvertently making choices
that reduce your chances of actually
building a valuable company. One of the
areas that we see this a lot are
companies that kind of have to bundle.
>> Yeah.
>> So look at HR's, right? And it's just
like whatever reason because why would
you want to buy 17 pieces of HR
software, right? Like the market wants
bundles. And we see companies all the
time like build a best-in-class product
and then struggle with do I do more? Do
I bundle?
>> Hell, we're seeing this with bigger
players now, right? If you're Zoom, if
you're Slack, right? You had these
decisions like we got to a certain size.
Do we build the bundle?
>> Yep.
>> If we don't, can we really the next
level?
>> Salesforce now. They got acquired.
>> Well, so it's part of a bundle.
>> Yeah. Another bundle. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. Right. These are conversations
that we never want to have with a
pre-product market fit company, right?
>> Yeah. If
again, let's use a specific example.
Let's say someone wants to build a new
cursor competitor.
>> Yes.
>> PrepMF, it's like, well, have you talked
to your users? Like, does anyone want
this? Is this better than cursor? Like,
it's just the fundamentals. Any midway
>> strategizing about whatever is
irrelevant if you have no users.
>> Your product is worse than nobody. Like
if no one will use it, you have a
problem. You know, if cloud code is just
way better, you're over.
>> Game over.
>> Yes.
>> But if you were sitting here right now
and watching this video and you had
raised a bunch of money or a series A
and you were the seventh most popular
>> Urser or Claude code competitor
and you've done no strategic thinking,
>> Yeah.
>> about what the plan is.
>> I think you're going to have a bad time.
Right.
>> Yes. And I think that there's another
misconception that happens that leads
people to believe being the seventh best
player is okay, which is well, if the
winner is generating 500 million in
revenue and we're generating 50 million
in revenue, we're just worth like
onetenth of the winner. And I don't
think I've ever seen this thought backed
up. In fact, I think that the assumption
is you're going to trend towards being
generally no revenue. Yes.
And I guess there are some markets where
there's six winners, but
and so it's interesting is in your
example, right? If you're the six
player, like you must be obsessed about
winning the whole game or just having a
move. There's got to be a move
>> or Yeah. or playing a different game.
Yeah. Yeah. We can win that one. And we
I think we encounter a lot of OC
founders who um and a lot of founders in
general who are kind of like, but isn't
50 million in revenue sufficient? Like
haven't I won?
>> Yeah.
>> Like isn't the finish line behind me?
Like I got here. If I got to 50, it's a
guarantee I'm going to get to 500,
right? One of the things I say to a lot
of founders is, "What do you think is
the failure rate for a series B
company?"
Because like I think in their minds
before I ask the question, they think
every series B company wins. And then
after I ask it, they're like, "I guess
mathematically that wouldn't work."
>> Yeah. So,
>> when they hear stuff like, "Yeah, 80
90%." They're like, "Oh, what's funny
about this nuance point we're making is
I could see a lot of people going like,
"Yeah, totally, guys. I agree with you,
but why aren't you doing all that during
the batch?" Again, I I don't think
people recognize how this style of
thinking no is literally poison when
you're trying to just ship a product,
but is absolutely necessary.
>> Well, I've even attack it in this way. I
think most of the times in your
pre-product market fit, you're still
trying to learn what the customer wants.
I would almost argue you're still in the
fundamental kind of let me learn what
the hell's going on. I think that like
when you're trying to make these high
strategic moves, it's very helpful that
you know some stuff. It's very helpful
that you have a mental model of the
customer. You have a mental model of
their needs. You have a mental model of
why your product helps them or not.
Like, and these are things that you're
still playing with pre-product market
fit. This kind of thinking creates
paralysis on a pre-product market. Like,
you know, instead of writing code today
and talking to users,
>> let's spend eight hours talking about
strategy, right?
>> Well, again, you go back to the Facebook
example, all of the strategic work
Zuckerberg did was super helpful with a
guy with 100 million MAU.
Like it's like cool man you here are the
keys. You get to spend a lot of time
pontificating.
>> Yes.
>> Having some some guy
>> Yeah.
>> sitting in his apartment strategizing
about the future of social networking.
>> Yeah.
>> That's not someone in a good position
>> to do this type of analysis.
>> When Zuck's got 2,000 Harvard kids,
that's not the time.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I love the point you made in the
beginning, which is that like this gives
us a little bit more time to flesh these
ideas out. I think another idea that you
introduced to me, which is I think is a
basic finance idea that I didn't fully
embrace at first is just comps. The
number of times I'm talking to founders
and I'm just like, what company do you
comp yourself to? Because if you're
trying to think strategically, like what
what does good look like? Where are we
aiming for? And a number of times people
will be like, oh well this company has a
billion dollar valuation. I'm comping
myself to them. And I'm like, I always
laugh now cuz I'm like, you have a sea
of public startups that you could, it's
like, you know, I don't want to learn
anything about playing basketball from
Michael Jordan because I like this guy
who plays on Duke right now. And I'm
like, all right, good. I like the Duke
guy is great. Like, maybe he'll make the
NBA. Like, can we talk about Michael
Jordan for a sec?
I like, oh, but Michael Jordan's old.
And I'm like, but he won. Go pick a
newer winner. Let's talk about liberal
100. Can we just talk about someone
who's
really put points on the board and we're
not judging them on what they might
accomplish in the future.
>> But founders resist this like, at least
in my own experience, is it seems so
foreign
>> to go public or to know anyone that did.
It just felt like being like,
>> "Let's talk about the astronaut who
walked on the moon." It just didn't seem
real. whereas now
>> it seems completely real, but we're in
the bubble, man. So again, I I think
>> I think that's my steel man on why
people I hear that, but I think, you
know, it's funny,
>> we've gotten to do a number of YC talks
with Tony from Door Dash. And like I
think he was thinking earlier than
anyone ever believe that like I want to
do delivery better than Amazon before he
ever had the right, you know, the
privilege to think that way. I think he
was thinking that way and that's just a
choice, right? Like he could have only
comped himself to Uber and Postmates.
>> Yeah. You choose who your heroes are.
Yeah. And I also think
it's more exciting.
Like it's scarier for sure, but it's
more exciting to compete against
the big big big players. All right, last
dangerous topic. So I I love I love
talking about this. So during early
stage fundraising, we often make fun of
investors who say, "What are you going
to do when Google builds your thing?"
It's often a sign of a unsophisticated
investor. I think it's because we heard
that so much when we were founders.
>> Yes.
>> Well, also there's no right answer.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's like Yes. If if Mark
decides to directly compete with you and
ignore everything else, how would you
win? It's like it's it almost feels like
an unfair question. But there is a stage
of company where the Google's, the
Amazons, the Salesforces, the the
Microsofts will take interest. I heard a
great story from a YC company doing a
CRM and he was like, "Have you ever
heard of Microsoft Dynamics?" I was
like, "I don't know about random
Microsoft products."
>> He's like, "Oh yeah, it's their CRM
that's taking like customers out of
Salesforce's hands left and right." And
I'm sitting here like,
"How many of our founders think
Salesforce has won?" Yeah.
>> And Microsoft's like, "Oh, this is
around the time, you know, in the last
five years. Let's let's start.
We could do that.
>> Or, you know, a classic example, right?
AWS.
>> Yeah.
>> Damn near a decade. They were the only
serious player.
>> Yeah.
>> Google. And then Microsoft's like, "Oh,
yeah, we could do that." And like the
crazy thing is like, "We can hire some
of the people who built your thing and
ask them, hey, now that you built it,
how would you do it better the next
time?" And so what seems like a dumb
question from a research founder, how
should a leader stage founder think
about these big guys because they do
compete? I think it's worth thinking
about
from your customer's perspective. You
know, just go through the laundry list.
How hard would it be for someone to
switch? Are there nonobvious reasons
that they wouldn't want to switch? I I
think just being really honest with
yourself about those things um is
probably a good idea. Like in the case
of Slack, I think what I heard again
this is not first party, this is just
third party. I think a lot more people
uh were willing to use Teams and other
stuff than Slack
>> and so was not as sticky as they had
hoped, which is part of why they needed
to get acquired. I believe that
Microsoft actually did damage to Slack
and that's why they got acquired was my
understanding.
>> It's funny. So I talked to somebody who
was like a product lead at Microsoft and
he was just like look like we could
bundle teams
and like we could effectively
almost default roll it out to all
Microsoft folks where every one of those
deals Zoom would have to get people to
adopt it upsell them figure out some IT
thing do all the contracting and
Microsoft was like this is the next
product in the suite. me a question that
is completely irrelevant to most YC
founders for their whole career is if
you're a product like Slack with the
amount of kind of takeoff that you had
or Zoom with the amount of takeoff that
you had
was there a way to compete against
office and like one of the things I
often think about is like there is a
point where you might actually have to
go at these big guys throats
>> I mean okay one more time to go go back
to the Facebook thing yeah Google
decided to kill Facebook with Google+
and they put like half the company on
it. Y
>> and it totally failed. But it's not cuz
they didn't try.
>> Nope. Nope.
>> It was not.
>> There was a very serious effort. Yes.
>> By Google to bury Facebook. Yeah. It
just didn't work out.
>> It's funny cuz it's kind of like I don't
know. I think about the ocean and just
different size fish and like when you're
a fish this small, you know, nobody the
great white doesn't care. But as you get
bigger,
you've got bigger competitors. And I
think that I almost wish that more
founders thought of that as empowering.
>> I thought of more founders like, "Hey,
now I get to competing against the big
guys because it's not like the big guys
have the better product." Often not,
>> right? Like you like often by competing
against the big guys, you can bring a
better product to market. And like I'll
use Door Dash as an example. I've been
an Amazon user for 25 years.
And I would have said I've loved Amazon
top five products in my life
>> for maybe 20 of them. And something
started happening about five years ago
where I would do an Amazon search.
>> I know. Yeah.
>> And it's like it's hard not to buy junk.
>> And I'm like, you have to really try to
not buy trash on Amazon. Like the whole
thing is set up to buy
>> the app button. Yes.
>> Yeah. You almost need to do discovery
outside of Amazon
deep link to the thing you want to buy
and otherwise stay the hell out of it's
all bad.
>> Well, and and the terrorism of getting
It's one thing when you sign up for some
service online, it doesn't work out and
you can just unsubscribe. The terrorism
of getting something physical in your
home and you're just like, "Okay, if I
have to return it, that's just even more
time." But then this and like or or just
like silly things like the photo was the
wrong size. So it's like Amazon started
putting this this product is often
returned and I'm like why is it in the
result?
It was like I have to scroll down to
learn. I'm sure some PM is going to get
sent this video. The email from the boss
have you seen this? Please consider you
know investor guys talking about it. You
know, one of the other thing is the the
sponsored products. Like Google taught
me that like sponsored stuff's at the
top and you scroll past it and then like
you get the real stuff for a while and
like you should be able to tell the
difference between ads and not ads.
>> Amazon's taught me like I don't even
know what's going on. Like is that an
ad? Is that not an ad? Are those reviews
fake? Are they real? I have to have a
plugin to tell me whether the reviews
are real or not. I'm like, on the other
hand, Door Dash, I and I can't even
believe I'm saying this. I'm like,
because Door Dash fulfills from the
local stores and like it's very hard for
random spam products to get
distribution in local physical stores.
When I order on Door Dash, I feel safer.
>> You get the thing.
>> Yeah. And it's like it's a thing that
kind of is like it's gonna it's a brand
I've probably heard of.
>> Yeah. And it's gonna work and it gets
there faster. And I feel such like a
rich douchebag as I'm sitting here like
I don't need these sneakers in an hour.
Like I don't like
>> but I'm not even using Door Dash because
I needed them in an hour.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm just using it. Yeah.
>> Right. You know it's like I feel
uncomfortable. I I mean Amazon Prime,
Amazon, I got all the Amazon stuff. I
got Echo throughout my whole house,
>> but I'm like, very interesting.
Door Dash is competing
against Amazon. Yep. They've decided
like we're going to take on the big boys
and the big boys maybe are a little more
vulnerable than they look.
>> And what's funny to cap this off is that
was always the plan. Like the comps
were, you said this a minute ago, but
the plan was always to imagine the size
of the logistics business for all
products was bigger than food only.
>> But first, you know what he had to do?
He had to get someone a burrito
in Palo Alto. Yeah. Right. You don't you
don't get to have this conversation
without how do I get someone a burrito
in Palo Alto?
>> So,
use this advice correctly. Don't come
back to us and don't yell at us. We
don't want to hear, you know, your
pre-launch companies, how do I take on
Google?
But if you do find yourself in a little
bit of a rut in your postpartum market
fit, maybe you got to be more ambitious,
which is counterintuitive.
>> All right.
>> All right. Thanks so much. Appreciate
it.